what's up out there ladies and gentlemen
it's Thursday hopefully you guys are
enjoying the witching hour store as I
put up earlier today I might record some
more later on today if I have time just
for like for next week so what are we
talking about today
okay dad all right so let's let's go
back Bao days was it two days ago three
days ago two days ago Pookie came up to
the back door lizard in its mouth so I
got down my knees and opened up this
glass sliding glass door was gonna grab
that lizard she dropped it and a lizard
ran into the house cheap yeah my name is
so I saw the lizard but go underneath
the bed and that's the last time I've
seen it no it's in the house we couldn't
find him it's like so we were looking
for him everywhere and we couldn't find
the lizard yeah the cat knows the
lizards in here well today Pookie
freaked out well you saw it in the
backyard
right so what happened I got up about
7:00 as I usually do I go into the
bathroom like before I go for my walk
and all of a sudden the lizard we
thought it would probably be dead by now
because it's been a couple days since I
didn't find it they can live for long
and so I'm in the bathroom and like the
lizard runs out from somewhere I don't
know if he was behind like the little
garbage can or whatever and I was like
you [ __ ] and like I leaned down
and tried to get him any ran under the
door so I go out of the bathroom and
immediately I come out of the bathroom
and like right next to the bathroom is
like the walk-in closet
Pookie is in the walk-in closet flippin
the [ __ ] out and she's doing her lizard
called peep peep peep peep like my mom
and like she was like over there by my
clothes like I have like some you know
clothes and stuff like stacks at least
about these shelves and she's just over
there like and she's like wigging out
she keeps turning around a look at me
and I'm like is he in there is he in
there she's like yeah maybe she tries to
talk and stuff like couple hours later I
heard a big [ __ ] commotion and she
was trying to climb up the damn coats
and so it must be you know the clothes
that are hung up most yeah and she's
gone back man man making the warning
sound
rare and I couldn't see it but now the
cat lives in the closet she's just yeah
she wants me in there in the closet
because when I got back from my walk she
was still in there like hunched over
like my clothes just looking and I was
like oh you are you garden you like wait
for you about with you like sitting I
looked all over I can't find a damn
thing I even looked as I because it was
right by the laundry hamper and like I
even was doing laundry and I was like
shook all the clothes out just in case
he ran in there to hide ya lizards can
last a long time indoors
frogs know the frog will only last 24
hours yes dry out is yeah because I used
to have some less some does it have
something to do with air conditioning
and they jump out of the tank and yeah
it kills him quick but it's just yeah
it's so funny the way she's just like
and she and she like come in the room
like to get you and be like follow me
yeah it's in here right but sliding
glass doors they don't belong that
bottom track they don't seal real well
and she'll chase him up against the
glass and when she's outside yeah some
up against the glass and they'll get in
the damn track and know they can come
right then I can like squeeze in take
squeeze right through ya sliding glass
door doesn't seal well they'll come
right in and you know a lizard can live
in here for a long time yeah it's like
there's so many little nooks and
crannies for them to hide so it's like
he I mean she must have seen him again
too because I've never seen her climbing
up my coats before she [ __ ] with like
stuff that's down near the ground climb
up - cuz I've never seen her climb when
she was calling for help trying to help
me catch this she didn't want help
catching it but yeah well the funny
thing too is like you were setting up
that that new TV and the minute you get
she knows that if you get the flashlight
out that you're either looking for her
if she says like that Orientalism or
you're looking for a lizard or a bug so
she's in the house and sees you get the
flashlight out she immediately will come
up right next to you go what what are we
looking for
yeah or is it something I can eat yeah
he was like just trying to like hook up
the TV and he couldn't really see and so
he had the flashlight she immediately
like came over - like what are you doing
is there a lizard yes
elizabeti TV she's funny she said funny
because she has like that particular
little call that's like a lizard because
I I think I mentioned on here before
there's a lizard that lives on the
outside of our bathroom window yeah
between the window and like in between
the window and the screen and she just
loves that so she jumps up on the on the
windowsill all the time and like tries
to get him even though he's on the other
side it's like I want you TV yeah and if
you go like up to her and be like hey
the lizard there and she'll turn around
and go like she has like this weird
little like peeping call that she takes
that has to do with like hey lizard yeah
oh yeah so we don't know where the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] lizard is I should say
speaking of animals too that um when I
was on my walk this morning I saw an
otter yeah yeah oh yeah I was like
walking and it we got otters in every
gay bar no it was like different kind of
otter yeah yeah so it was it was
actually I went out at like 7:00 or 7:30
this morning it was like really really
overcast and it was like kind of
sprinkling and the path is like cut most
of it is pretty dark anyway because it's
like you know the trees like grow over
so it's like a tunnel and I was coming
nut and I saw something like way off on
the path and I was like that that's not
a squirrel I was like that looks too big
to be a squirrel but too small to be a
cat and I was like and it wasn't moving
like and I was like and it's not moving
like an armadillo because they had that
kind of bumbly kind of walk and I was
like what the [ __ ] is that and then like
I got closer and it was a little otter
and he was going across because that's
where that swampy thing is over there
like with where the alligators are I
guess he was going over there to the
other side but yeah so I was pretty cool
yeah I've seen that otters out here but
five feet long yeah this one was not as
big as that one we saw running across
the road dog yeah that was like it that
was a big one this one was that wasn't a
baby but it looked like it was smaller
than a cat it was probably about Pookie
size yeah and she's like small for a cat
you know what I mean yeah so is there
anything else we got to talk about um oh
we wanted to mention that movie that we
saw on shutter last night this is one
that's like I guess it's not it's not
new enough to be on the matinee show but
it's not old enough to be on that
perspective I had seen it they posted on
shutter
like a while back and I just hadn't got
around to it because they keep adding
new things all the time and I'm like oh
let's watch that yeah what's it called
its called patchwork patchwork yeah
pretty good it came out like when I
looked it up because I was curious like
um you know who directed and what the
reviews were like in stuff so I looked
it up today and it says that it came out
on 2017 but the copyright notice at the
end of the credits was 2015 so I don't
know if it just like you know took a
long time to come out or it's a lot like
reanimate er it actually has reagent in
it well and it is a shout out to the guy
who made R and it's not alike I'm kind
of like what would happen if we animator
was also Frank and hooker and a chick
and a chick flick like a horror comic
three girls that are very different from
each other gets sewn together into one a
body and yeah they get hit with reagent
but they're mentally all there which
that's not really explained but it
doesn't matter that thing's just a
comedy it's fun
I liked it very much it's like it's a
more female centric take on you know
like Franken who ker yeah or you know
re-animator and actually I was reading
this and okay so there's this blog
called a horror society I think it was
called and they had reviewed this movie
and they loved it very much and they had
a theory and they had a pretty
compelling case that they thought that
this was like a stealth sequel to the
reanimated movies like this was son
ovary animator because they pointed out
they're like not only they point out
that the reagent is in this but also
that the doctor that's in it like the
mad scientist that puts the three women
together they never mentioned what his
name is
yeah and at one point there's just like
a throwaway line where he some says
something about his doing it to like
impress his father or like you know he
says something like you know like screw
you dad or so like you thought I'd never
amount to anything or something like
that so they're speculating they're like
well maybe they couldn't like get the
rights to do a reanimate er you're I
think like son of reanimate er but this
is like you know in omage to that and
he's supposed to be like Herbert West
son yeah it makes sense which actually I
was like yeah [ __ ] it didn't even occur
to me because even like the UM like I
said they thanked Stewart
at the end and the opening credits are
very reanimate arest lick they're
animated like with the little body pull
morph daughter and it's kind of more of
a modern spin on it you know the mean I
mean their text and the little text
bubbles are popping up I liked it it was
good it was just like uh like like you
said it's a chick flick version of
reanimate er yeah kiss like you ever wet
the Sun of Herbert West is not the main
character it's the girls yeah he's only
in it a little bit yeah so it's really
just kind of like a horror comedy based
on these girls that wake up and they're
all sewn together into one and then they
have to like all cooperate yet like to
get you know kids because each of their
parts are like a different part and they
have to like you know there takes him
awhile like learn to watch she's kind of
like a damn super zombie she's strong
and they're getting revenge on the
ex-boyfriends and [ __ ] you know it's
just you know it wasn't so much
ex-boyfriends are just do well because
they're like looking for the guy that
sewed them together that's part of and
there's a twist in there too but I'm not
gonna spoil what it is yeah but er it's
good you can go see it for free yeah it
was just like one that I kinda came
across and then like I said from kind of
research in it then I found out that a
lot of horror blogs have reviewed it and
it's getting it got like really really
good reviews
yeah so yeah it's definitely worth
watching like I said it was a good thing
to talk about because you know it's too
old to be on the matinee show then
watching stuff about AMC Theatres in its
history and everything and in the past
few years you know I mean it's history's
actually been kind of kind of janky in a
way Chinese gangsters buying it and then
the gangsters killed a [ __ ] British
businessman to hear about that mmm it
was thousands of a Glee was owned by a
group is this Chinese group that well
actually I said he's China Chinese guy
who owned a group of contra companies I
forgot what it was called you know they
all sound sound like Wei Phan or some
[ __ ] like that you know one of those
guys
Wei Phan group and him and another
Chinese billionaire killed a British
billionaire and the police over there in
China tried to cover it up and they all
got caught they all ended up getting
sentenced to like life sentences for a
murder and [ __ ] and then the comp
it's just the weird I didn't realize
that you know AMC kind of had a weird
history although
he wasn't involved in the day of the
operations of of AMC it was just part of
his holdings yeah because a lot of those
big conglomerates and it's like I don't
really have anything to do right
business is like on the ground
right I mean they just owned them like
along with tons of other yeah and then
the program I watched them goes into
what what's been going on with AMC and
what how's it gonna you know what's it
gonna be like in the post streaming
world you know and it's gonna it yeah I
don't I haven't changed my opinion out
and neither have the creditors I don't
think it's gonna come back in the form
that we remembered if it does come back
it's kind of a shame cuz AMC has been
around a long time because more than a
hundred years yeah like that's been a
rather [ __ ] ages yeah almost I think
yeah most on cuz I was watching
something [ __ ] what did I say maybe it
was company man or something like that
he might have done a show about them and
I was surprised at how long they had
been around but I mean they've been
around like almost since the beginning
of movies they kind of brought the
multiplex a superplex thing yeah they
were the first ones to do I believe the
United States they got it from a German
idea yeah yeah but you know there was
one german multiplex like that and he he
was an ex air force guy you know
something's World War two vet and he
he's he was the one that decided he
wanted to do it that way it was a family
business for a long time it was yeah but
it was a company man about it cuz I I'm
pretty sure I remember seeing like a
really complex like breakdown of their
history oh that's also a good channel
company man if you're interested in like
corporate history and like the history
of companies and brands and stuff that's
really yeah I don't think it's gonna
make it though it might not like I said
it's probably just gonna have to go and
the shame about it is that you know even
if it does go to streaming it's like now
there's so much competition in that area
that it probably because it's kind of a
late comer to that game it if Amazon
were to buy it they would immediately
rename it so would it be MC note would
yeah and that's like the the hope but I
don't think Amazon really wants to do
with physical with a physical theater I
mean they're an internet-based
although I heard like a year or two ago
that am
was interested in they started buying
like physical like brick-and-mortar like
bookstores and stuff like that for
whatever reason I don't know yes they
thought it was is to get their hands on
the real estate it's not on the business
yeah that's maybe that's but they just
started buying like a bunch of
bookstores and I remember well that's a
common theme and thing is to just buy up
a bunch of businesses that are going
under you don't give a [ __ ] about the
business really yeah you just want that
the assets and you want the property
that it sits on well yeah that there's
happen when that big corporation right
the newspaper that I'm usually when they
do that they own so many other companies
they can pad the blow when it goes under
because they own all the financial
companies they got ties in with the bank
so doesn't hurt her when they've got a
business they make money when it goes
out of business
yeah because it because there are other
companies somehow well yeah because they
own so much a so much so much other [ __ ]
it doesn't matter that that business
[ __ ] you went under because they're
gonna move one of their other ones on
there it's a billion what some day in
there he's gonna move another one of
their multi-billion dollar businesses
onto that property and then that one
will make more they they keep we gets to
a certain point where when you own so
much stuff your businesses do business
with your other businesses yeah so you
know I mean the money is like money it's
like second the money's just flowing
between businesses that you own so you
can't lose just yeah yes so you can't
lose yeah just a point where you you
know you have so much money you can't
lose money man
imagine that yeah yeah Bounty's gonna
come back no probably not
I mean it's been so long I mean I was
thinking the other day that I think this
is our 31st sidetracks show yeah it
means we've been doing this for a month
we decided went by fast yeah so that's
like pretty [ __ ] crazy to think about
I know it doesn't seem like it's been a
month since we started doing these yeah
but I guess it is so uh you done yes all
right so you got [ __ ] I got a dick
alright so have a good rest of your
Thursday and we'll see you guys again
tomorrow